madonna's son Rocco Ricci was arrested  for possession of marijuana  ét can confirm this happened nearly two  months ago in London the Metropolitan  Police arrested the 16 year old after  officers conducted a stop and search  raka was then taken to a North London  police station before he was bailed out  authorities say Rocco was dealt with by  way of triage which uses multiple  strands to engage and educate young  people in order to prevent reoffending  Rocco has been living in London with his  dad Guy Ritchie since late last year  amid a long custody battle over his  living arrangements in September the  family settled the custody matter  outside of court for her part Madonna  has shown no signs of a strange  relationship with her son regularly  sharing throwback photos of her boy  you